I couldn't bring myself to sleep in our
bed alone we lost two hours with HR died
we had a funeral maybe we should give us
all permission to grief
why don't we gonna bury dead empty suit
in the lab it's up to us to protect the
city because there is no one else just
us trying to keep the city safe were
barely getting it done
we need to bring Barry back no Barry
told us to keep moving forward not to
save him what is your deal it's like you
don't even want him back you're certain
that Barry is even still alive
Pyrus he's gotta be you need to believe
that there is an answer for every
question Aaron's trying to send us a
message I know it
you guys strike the baby girl we just
need a little faith let's bring our boy
home I try to keep go to keep my keys
you need to prepare yourselves marry
this guy's no joke he said he wants to
fight the flood
we made you a new suit I'm gonna take it
for a spin
he's back and there's a new trailer so
let's break down this flash I was
expecting them to release some new
footage and it's just an extended
version of the episode one trailer so
there's a new brand of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video make sure you click that Bell to
enable alerts so you don't miss any of
the videos because it is coming back at
the beginning of October so there'll be
a whole bunch of flash stuff happening
in the next couple of weeks
but the extra stuff we see here is sort
of the suit reveal the way they tease it
underneath that tarp they haven't taken
it off we've seen other pictures of it
in the other promos this is what it
looks like but this is kind of janky
footage so it's not quite as bright as
it actually looks in the final episodes
but how controversial do you think that
it's going to be when that first episode
drops and it seems like iris is the
person in the group that doesn't want to
go get Barry back now you understand why
like they don't provide context in this
clip but I can already see all the
people complaining on Twitter about this
so I think the explainer there is that
you know in the trailer she says Barry
wanted us to move forward and she
doesn't understand the speedforce
really none of them understand the Speed
Force that well so they don't understand
that he doesn't die when speedsters die
they go into the Speed Force so I know a
lot of you asking about reverse flash
when he got vaporized at the end of
legends of tomorrow he just went into
the Speed Force so he's just this
creature of pure energy but that gets a
little more complicated because when
reverse flash comes back it could be
from a different time period or it could
be the version that died
it'll probably be a different version
though but they T this up like you
looked at the similarities between this
episode when you see the signs of Barry
coming back the coffee in the cup starts
to rise they're treating this sort of
like a reboot of the show so that's why
you're seeing a lot of visual things
that they did back during season one
[Music]
remember how cool it was when things
would get really quiet and all of a
sudden you'd see liquids start to rise
and that let you know that a speedster
was about to jump into the area usually
before the reverse-flash showed up but
it's also what happened the first time
the Barry was struck by the lightning
and infused with the Speed Force
so when Cisco says he's trying to send
us a sign it sounds like random events
start happening all over the city and
they're not sure what's happening but
they get the idea that it's P Force
related so they just assumed that it's
Barry I like the way that they assume
that and I think that's kind of the idea
the whole thing is about bringing him
back I think it's a little too soon to
tease reverse-flash but just remember
when you see Speed Force things there
are a number of different types of
speedsters that can cause that but
because they've been playing up the
mystery of Barry maybe being dead even
though if you've read the comics you
know that he's not dead I think all
their conclusions are right I'm really
curious to see who's behind the samurai
it's because in the comics there's this
specific Japanese character if he's not
gonna be just a one-off thing he might
just be a stepping stone in the thinker
slowly working things out but the way
they pitched the character earlier this
year doesn't make it sound like he's
going to be doing a lot of things in the
first episode that are super evil like
the character description they gave for
him is somebody who's correcting what he
sees is this great imbalance and
injustice in the world so it sounds like
he's not a super big fan of all the
collateral damage that the heroes have
been causing so it's not so much that
he's trying to steal something from
Barry it's just that he feels like
they're all bad people just as bad as
the villains I think and there's still a
lot of questions about that but just
keep that in the back of your mind the
thinker's someone who feels he can make
the world a better place in a better way
than the flash can but it looks like
they reverse engineer the Speed bazooka
from last year to bring Barry back I
open a time portal exposing the Speed
Force you shoot me with that and I
become fragmented throughout
of time the past present future this
device here that they set on the ground
that starts glowing that looks like
something brand-new in the episode but I
am wondering if they're gonna full-blown
release a promo with him actually
wearing this suit that would be pretty
badass but I think the whole thing here
is that you bring him back he saves iris
from the samurais like that's what all
these police officers for he grabs her
and takes her up into the sky that's
probably when we'll see him wear the
suit for the first time like Cisco might
unfurl it and then you'll just see like
a flash of lightning as he runs out and
you won't actually see him standing
still in it until he saves iris like
it'll be some big reveal but it's hard
to tell if this footage from an earlier
promo is from the first episode or the
second episode because he turns around
and he's smiling like he recognizes
Cisco and it doesn't seem like that's
gonna happen till the second episode but
I've already done a video about the
weird Speed Force symbols that you see
him drawing at the end there's a lot of
theories about that and I think it'll
just plan over the course of the season
so I'll link that video at the end of
this but it involves the movie arrival a
lot of you have also referenced the
Smallville episode where Lionel Luthor
tried to enter Clark's cave he tried to
get access to all the Kryptonian
knowledge and it drove him crazy and he
started writing Kryptonian symbols all
over the place
the disciples of Zod they must be
stopped but that was a little bit
different he was turned into a prophet
by all these Sun crystals and that's not
exactly what the flash is doing the
flash himself I guess you could call him
a speed force prophet but he'll be back
to normal Barry within the first couple
of episodes with the memories of all
these things that he knew when he was
existing beyond space-time like past
present and future all simultaneously so
they be some crazy mythology to dig
through in that first episode Phil
teased a lot of the ongoing mysteries
without revealing everything I'm not
expecting to actually see the thinker on
screen till after the first couple of
episodes and I believe that the
elongated man won't debut till episode
four or five it's a little bit later in
the season but we haven't seen any
footage from the set of him yet so I'll
be interested to see and obviously any
of the behind the scenes stuff that
might drop won't have CG so until we get
a promo for his episode we're not really
gonna see what he looks like when he's
using his powers but hopefully they'll
release a comic book posters they
haven't done that in a while but because
they did that back during season one and
two and they're going back to season one
and to stuff in season four maybe
they'll start doing that again but the
other thing that's happening is I
changed the way I do episode videos just
a little bit like have you been watching
my Rick and Morty or you watch my Game
of Thrones videos this past year they
look a little bit more like that just
the way the videos move so season to
season I always try to change the way I
do things just a little bit based on
feedback so if there's anything that you
guys really want me to do a video for
for the flash or there's things that I'm
not including it videos that you want me
to start just let me know in the
comments but what will happen is is I
was in the middle of making new Rick and
Morty when this drops so that'll be my
next video to post then I have some new
Game of Thrones so we'll say
congratulations to the newest giveaway
winners a p-please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details you can click here
to learn all about those mystery
speedforce symbols and you can click
here for brand new Rick and Morty thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight